i i mean it's just so [ __ ] crazy how
numb we are to everything like
the ufo [ __ ] everybody coming out i
think we were talking about this i don't
know if it was on a pod or maybe it was
off the pod we were just talking about
it idiots
oh it's on idiots yeah it's like we're
so [ __ ] like
everybody's coming out they got all
these politicians they even selling
obama obama please tell [ __ ]
there's
there's aliens just go out there and we
don't care we don't care if there's
aliens we don't care that they basically
just admitted that the security guards
for epstein
yeah uh i didn't know that oh the
security guards for epstein
were basically convicted
of not checking on epstein the night
that he got killed we all knew they
weren't
but and then they got community service
for it because like they were willing to
like work
on the uh like yeah we'll work on the
case yeah sure you're gonna work on the
investigation you're being investigated
by the [ __ ] that know exactly
what happened yeah
yeah come on bro but how crazy is that
like
this happened we we have them basically
admitting going yeah we [ __ ] up well
now we [ __ ] up but
yeah we didn't check on him the night
that he uh
committed suicide yeah yeah and we don't
care i think the deal is like
what happened i'm sorry i think the deal
with them is like they were basically
like yo
shut your mouth don't say anything about
it don't do a book don't do a movie
because i think a lot of people have
been trying to get them and be like
yo explain what happened so i think the
deal is like yeah we'll give you a
lesser sentence just shut your mouth
uh-huh how are they what are the charges
uh the charge with negligence for their
job because essentially they were just
there watching tv
yeah but there's a chance that this is
what they did like they didn't actually
go check on the sale every house
trust me that's how is that true that's
how it happens in the direction
so yeah but if it's epstein you know you
got to check on this [ __ ]
and if someone's on suicide watch maybe
they don't give a [ __ ] about this thing
so this
so is is interesting because al's got
perspective on this because al
used to do this not corrections
right and uh where he was being held
used to work yeah
right you used to work at the tunes yeah
we called the tombs what's it called uh
i mean i think new york is still
referred to as a tune but uh manhattan
correctional facility
okay so that's where he's being held and
so it is common that that officers or
corrections officer the
or the whatever the security guards
there won't do the rounds
because you're like they're locked up
what the [ __ ] is really going to happen
or you do it a few times a night now
that being said
it feeds the conspiracy if we all
believe they didn't do it on purpose
yeah and we kind of all want to believe
the conspiracy because it's so [ __ ]
absurd
and at this point you gotta believe
something some part of this conspiracy
is right yeah it might not be all of it
but some part
if you deny every single part of it
you're a [ __ ] face yeah the official
story is wrong
we just don't know which thing is wrong
exactly so now every new bit of
information that comes out
feels like it further confirms the
conspiracy oh these two officers were in
on it
they knew that this was happening the
whole time and that's why they neglected
to check
when the average corrections officer was
like man we don't have to be checking on
these [ __ ] especially if it's
at night we watching some on netflix
[ __ ] these guys
so it's tricky man or what if now they
know we don't care so they're just like
let out everything that people have been
dying to know
so i'm not gonna give a [ __ ] maybe get
used to it because we're also ready to
get out aliens are here and we're like
hey but whatever there's outside their
places are open let's go eat
we don't care about aliens we don't care
about the epson [ __ ] what the [ __ ] do we
care about
we care about getting back outside and
seeing people we just want to party
you're right now is this time to tell us
whatever they [ __ ] need to tell us
tell us what happened jfk
yeah tell us about the the eddie what
else is there
oh uh i saw i think there was a former
fbi agent
says they know the person who shot
biggie
tell us that [ __ ] behind you but uh yeah
r.i.p
but like tell us that [ __ ] they know the
person but they won't release their name
because they're
like something in conjunction with the
lapd and they
they gotta shut up yeah all right well
boom tell us about biggie tell us about
the moonlight
tell us about moon landing tell us about
all the [ __ ] it's lit
i i'm with we don't care we just want to
be outside we're gonna get it all out
right now we'll care about it later
you